foreign
[Music]
hello hello we did an interview together
the other day and I don't remember your
hair looking this fabulous I think he
was wearing a hat maybe okay I don't
know I'm like I love the longer look too
long is it you're gonna cut it I don't
know don't do it well it looks so cool
you've got the natural curl thing going
it's cool well thanks just saying I just
get frustrated having to do it in the
morning says every woman on the planet
join us yeah did you make any
resolutions for 23
I didn't make any resolutions I but I I
have a few things on my mind goals and
Ambitions yeah I feel like with the
resolutions it's kind of like set up for
for failure every time so I just kind of
approached it with some some personal
goals and professional goals yeah
um you know there's a lot on the person
front obviously being a new father yeah
so that's taking up
you're gonna try most of my time this
year exactly yeah I was like There's No
Sleep your daughter turned one right
though right um or she's about to turn
one she did yeah yeah well over the over
the weekend okay over the weekend okay
she's there a big party we did yeah yeah
a little you know he had to celebrate
she went through a pretty wild journey
in the early part of her life
um and so we we had to celebrate in
style yeah she's uh she's one she's
beautiful it's amazing she's adorable
yeah oh my gosh I have to ask before we
start on this
um I saw that I'm obsessed with
Bridgerton oh because I have eyes and
ears and
um and I saw that you posted this so I
want to show this and then you stomp and
then
hey it's very fitting oh my God it's all
about the hair so people so you love
those yeah I get a lot of tweets saying
that we look like some of the bridges
and brothers uh bridging guys so
um I decided it was time that I put on
the gear I was gonna wear it today but I
just felt like I don't know it would be
a little bit too much that would have
been awesome for me next time um yeah
wait y'all should dress up as that for
like Halloween I'm just saying Halloween
show maybe I'm just yeah I'm just saying
it would be really good yes let's do it
I want to come I actually saw their
concert this isn't in the script
um your concert was so amazing thank you
[Applause]
I've seen it's such a good time my
girlfriends we went anyway had a good
time
um but so wait you recently ventured
into this so I didn't know about this
and I was talking I guess we were
texting about it recently yeah this
popcorn is amazing it's called Rob's
backstage popcorn like how did this
start so this is kind of a wild story
but basically our very good friend Greg
played bass with us for many years uh
wrote a bunch of songs of them I went
over his house one night uh about 10
years ago and his dad asked if we were
hungry and I said sure it came out with
a brown paper bag of popcorn and started
shaking it around and I tried some of it
it was pretty much a version of what
we're going to taste today and I was
blown away fell in love with it and I
kept saying can we please bring this to
the world turn this into a real brand uh
and then we finally did a couple years
ago launched it on our last tour yeah I
remember this tour and and now it's here
right and I have to you I I told you
this I think I don't know if I texted
this but I but literally when we went to
your show my nanny was he was like oh my
God we've got to try this popcorn
everybody talks about this popcorn I was
like what and I was like what do you
mean it's a Jonas Brothers I was like
what and it sold out yeah oh really we
were there so early and it sold out so
fast and then I asked him to send me
some and I know why it's sold out
because it's so good and I ate two bags
it tends to happen so good I couldn't
stop eating it um so The Man Behind The
Jonas approved popcorn is here to teach
us how to make it so do you want to
introduce them I would love to okay uh I
would like to introduce everyone to the
man in the myth Legend yes The Man
Behind Rob's backstage popcorn this is
Rob garbowski yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
okay Rob I'm gonna lead with this I ate
two bags with my kids like in a sitting
like and granted we hadn't had dinner
but this was our dinner it was so good
and you don't have to have because it's
like sweet and salty right well done is
what I'm saying thank you well done it's
delicious so let's make it great things
okay let's do it how do we where do we
start okay I think we got some oil
heating up in there right so we can pour
it go ahead and pour the kernels in are
you pouring okay
[Laughter]
I'm obsessed with this popcorn and I
could not let the audience just sit
there and watch us taste this amazing
popcorn so if you want to grab the bag
under your chair and eat with us
[Applause]
yeah nice shake it up I'm telling you
what that's one of my favorite gifts
we've ever given away on this show it's
so good and try not to eat the whole
damn bag
um so what what do y'all think somebody
taste it y'all let me know I'm just
saying I'm just saying
well I like your hands it's the sweet
and salty
sing happy face it's a sweet and salty I
can't speak as they're eating which is a
good sign and I will say like you
mentioned the salt and the sweet yeah
the other part is that savory yeah and
it really was a matter of trying to just
nail those three parts because any one
of them can overwhelm the other I know
but the chemistry is hey yep yeah it
took a while last night I found a tiny
bit left in one of the bags that I ate
it in my bed there you go while watching
Vikings Valhalla oh nice
Rob would show up to our tour with just
giant bags oh wow
all right
so let's put the popcorn in the bags
okay okay just be careful it's hot
very good all right so grab the
seasoning okay all right let's put it
down in there you're all right let's
talk about this little grease
okay now we're gonna do a little
competition see who does the best job of
shaking it up wait how much did you put
in just just gotta feel it yeah yeah
that was good okay
what up what up Kevin are you ready are
you ready for this wow
Haley's got it
I'm so excited
I love your bow and arrow box
I can't wait I want to taste it here we
go
oh it's fresh out of the oven out of the
pot okay I'm not Rob hold on wow
that's good it is so good Rob this is
the best popcorn I've ever had I'm not
kidding really good so let's talk about
it I know people probably ask you a time
but I love Priyanka and you know this me
too so cool but I didn't realize I
will be really I didn't realize like how
fast like okay what was your first date
like first of all well it's kind of a
long story
um but I'll I'll tell it so basically we
um we were told by a mutual friend that
we should meet and uh he said I'll
connect you guys he never did and I got
impatient so I direct messaged her on
Twitter uh and she she responded we
talked on you know back and forth about
a year on text and then we finally met
in person and it wasn't it wasn't really
a date it was just met in person and
went for a drink and then about a year
later we went on our first official date
to the Hollywood Bowl to go see the
Beauty and the Beast live uh and it's
adorable you know just recently we
played there to kind of end the first
leg of the tour and she sat two boxes
away from where we sat on her first date
it was very cool that's so cool so what
I didn't know though is y'all got y'all
got married pretty quick like people I
heard people kept going whoa that's
moving fast first of all stay in your
lane exactly mind your own business so
mind yourself
um no I think when you know when you
know you know we heard that pretty much
from everybody once we told people we
were engaged uh but we it all you know
it was It was kind of magical you know
just within uh eight nine weeks we were
you know talking about marriage within
10 11 weeks we were engaged
um and we got married in December last
year so our one year is coming up on the
first that's exciting congratulations
really cool
[Applause]
I heard when I was doing the I was
reading the pre-interview for this I had
no idea that y'all opened for me in
2005. because I feel like I just got
really cool no so no one cared about us
in 2005 we were just coming up and
basically to get other gigs we listed
the other acts that we'd opened up for
but that really just meant that we were
on like the outside stage in the parking
lot while you were playing for forty
thousand people still the same she
helped us get a lot of gigs after that
so thank you we owe you 20.
so now you're on a tour for real so tell
us about happiness begins uh yeah so
this has been you know quite the crazy
year for the family
um you know just a year ago right now we
had just started recording music uh to
get together again and um you know
looking a year later we're finishing up
the first leg of a crazy tour and and
um also the album you know happiness
begins but it all started with the
documentary which we call chasing
happiness which was kind of just to tell
our story of our childhood you know our
father was a pastor and we had a pretty
uh crazy journey in the church and then
into our music career together and uh we
had really no intention of getting the
band back together but after filming for
a little while and kind of healing some
of those family wounds that were there
from our years of working together in
the past we were able to look at this
with a fresh View and and really kind of
all in different ways find our happiness
and so we we went for it and it's been
an unforgettable year it's been really
amazing I will say you
famous family ever
someone listed in your family tree I'm
like oh hey well those kids are going to
be like they're not going to know what
normal is they are like I have some cool
ants it's amazing y'all should have her
you shouldn't but you should have a
reality show I just want to see it I
just want to I want to watch the dynamic
of all those famous people in one family
that's I think the band might break up
again
if cameras are there all the time no you
won't you have to be on point it's great
to see you
good to see you we don't have actually
we have wow
fraternity sort of thing yes I want to
come
um okay so we're gonna we're gonna talk
popcorn in a minute uh but first you and
your wife
incredible
yeah excited thank you this is our
second installment of the book
um you know there's a beach in my
bedroom you know we're just it's all
about disappointment and understanding
what to do when things have to change
and in our life with as much as our life
can change in a drop of a hat sometimes
you're expecting to do one thing and you
have to shift and so this is kind of
about that oh my gosh pivoting is hard
as a parent too yes
Valentina hey we're not doing this today
but you promise yeah you said I could
have ice yeah exactly but yeah that was
before 18 candy bars that you had
exactly thank you
um well among their many many Ventures
Kevin and his brothers have a popcorn
line it's incredible it's called Rob's
backstage popcorn oh I don't know last
time you may have your own version I may
have my fantastic incredible flavor oh
last month Nick came by to unveil
actually their newest flavor it's called
Kelly's classic barbecue it's amazing
I'm it's actually addictive I'm sorry
and you're welcome
um you had a contest in connection with
the flavors released so it ended in a
tie it did it's incredible isn't it we
have two amazing players they it was as
a filter you had to catch popcorn in
your mouth on you know on the on the
Instagrams yeah look at that on the
ground there
um sadly we ended at his high so what
better way to do it than have it come to
life and do it in real life so we have
the two gentlemen in our audience who
tied for first so let's say hello to
Josh and cam everybody what's up hi Josh
okay
do you mind
um doing this contest firstly tiebreaker
do you mind hosting I am honored and I'm
thrilled okay
I was training in the art of Pop and
tossing and catching uh why don't why
don't y'all come down here right now
Josh and cam uh so we can get this
tiebreaker started
America well we've broken you into two
teams representing Rob's backstage
popcorn Kevin and cam our team sweet and
salty let's hear it for that Kelly and
Josh are team barbecue yes
now while Kelly and Kevin are part of
the competition they have one role in
one role only okay moral support that is
it they cannot help their teammates in
any other way all right Cam and Josh you
will have 30 seconds to catch as many
kernels as you can one Colonel at a time
your hand must go below your face and
the kernel must be tossed above your
head to count and if we tie again we'll
go to sudden death
all right Kelly and Kevin you want to
show them how it's done yeah absolutely
I need Redemption here you go
[Applause]
there are official judges from Rob's
backstage popcorn standing by to
determine the official winner
all right fellas Cam and Josh he all set
we're ready all right let's get 30
seconds on the clock you're gonna do it
go Vibes go
you're amazing
you are killing it
[Music]
[Applause]
oh my God
wait what
judges
Pam and Josh you guys really put your
all into this and so of course we don't
want to let anyone leave empty-handed so
we're giving you Josh five thousand
dollars
[Applause]
that's incredible thank you
Colin Hanks was recently on the show
um and well he said this someone came up
to me and said what's up fake Nick Jonas
and the reason why they said that was
because in Jumanji I play like the main
kid that gets sucked into the game and
in the game I was played by Nick Jonas
but in real life when you come back and
you live your life yeah so in reality
yeah he's fake Colin Hanks but no one
calls him that that's rude
not for the record I've never been told
okay oh you never been called that oh
that's so interesting yeah but um I just
hope that you don't confuse us because
we've we've had a lot of history now
totally I didn't not at all not at all
like I just I well I mean you hold on
this is the real test amongst friends
wait what am I now am I in your phone as
no you were I mean it's just Nick Jonas
yeah well just nature there's there's
nothing there's no no
um
well calling you now no it's totally
well it might it might okay
it might say fake calling Hanks
look look
okay it was funny it was funny and I'm
like no one calls you
no one calls you fake calling it's like
my own my monthly trip to your show it's
my only it's my look I'm the only one
with this really cool Nick
yeah yeah because
nobody would you said nobody does that
but it is funny that he gets called fake
news I love him and I loved playing
um and I I've only ever met him once oh
really we have played each other
twice now in two jumanjis that
yeah so and actually I I have spent more
time
um with uh his parents than him oh his
parents are fun very fun yeah love her
um okay so and love him um but last time
you and your brothers mentioned that
you're working on new music so asking
for a friend what how's that going
when am I going to get some music we're
usually like really cryptic about this
and and I just kind of feel like that's
really stupid I don't know why we do
that yeah um so we're working on new
music for sure okay and I can tell you
I'm excited I love your music I can tell
you that I think it's my favorite stuff
we've ever done and
um it's it's you know basically a uh an
evolution of the sound in a way that I
think is really natural for us and and
feels uh like a great next step and
we're working with some people we've
always wanted to work with and I can't
wait for everyone to hear it
[Applause]
time that you
I loved your show like I had never been
able to like really watch a full show
and it's so interesting because it would
be on the voice and you forget like
you're sitting next to like I'm like oh
you're like super talented like I'm like
you you just forget because you're all
just hanging out and I was at your show
and I was like holy I know him I was
like I was like I was like it was just
so we can't say that on daytime but
whatever but I but I was just freaking
out because y'all were so good it was
this songs were so good the energy was
so good the crowd like loved it and I
loved the fact that the crowd was like
totally all different walks of life like
all different types that's my favorite
kind of crowd where you're like nowhere
would you find these people that's my
favorite kind of musical crowds I agree
with stuff like music can do that like
bring randos to absolutely can and I
feel like uh the fun thing in this last
couple years specifically has been that
we've really seen that distinction of
you know beyond the the kind of OG fans
who've been there forever yeah
um to a lot of the the the older people
who have come to our shows perhaps watch
The Voice or other things yeah the
younger people who were introduced to us
in the last couple years and think we're
a new band it's like oh my God like oh
yeah people think you're doing this
that's my favorite thing that people do
like if I perform swimming they're like
oh my gosh you can sing and I'm like
well
I'm like uh well little and I'm like
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
guys I'm going home
[Music]